so last week i put a poll on my channel
asking you guys what you wanted to see
more of
and most of you actually voted for
architects training
so today i'm going to show you something
extremely special
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
firstly if you're new here thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and
architecture as a registered architect
here in the state of western australia
i'm here to show you guys and share with
you my passion about architecture and
technology
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button
because today we are talking about
archicad and how
exactly you can design like an architect
in a very
very special environment now before we
get into it i want to let you guys know
that the model behind me
you see that has been completely modeled
in twin motion
so you can import any single project
over top of it is available for download
right now in the link below
so if you want to check it out and grab
this model for yourself it's there for
you to download
right now okay so today i wanted to
focus on how we can actually design
something in archicad but also how we
can design it
as an architect and through an
architect's mind
now obviously there's a lot of training
that goes on into becoming an architect
and
there's a lot more to learn than just
how you design something
but i really wanted to showcase you guys
how we can
take something like this which is
actually a real live environment
very close to my house which is
absolutely beautiful hence why i try to
replicate it in twin motion
and share with you guys so you can
create something of your own but at the
same time i really wanted to be able to
showcase
the design process and how we go from
absolutely nothing
no ideas in our head to creating
something on archicad that we can take
to our clients
so today we're going to start in
archicad 24
opened up a brand new australian
template completely blank
what i've done is drawn a red square
that indicates
the floor plate that we can actually
work with in this
model over here so if i bring the model
into view you'll see
that the twin motion model that we're
working with is a beach environment
it is absolutely stunning in real life
and looks even better than what it does
right now on this screen i've broken
down this model into a number of
elements
that you guys can manipulate as well so
on the right hand side we have our scene
we can remove our mash trees
and we can also remove our mass
vegetation
now i'm showing this straight away
because with all of those layers on even
my computer struggles and is a little
bit slow
however with those layers turned off we
can see what we're working with
so we're working with a full mountain
environment
all the way around surrounded by
beautiful tropical water
and we have our main site on the right
hand side here
so what i've gone ahead and done is
created this sort of driveway coming
up the ground from the sand and the
natural environment
onto somewhat of a protected cliff face
now in real life this site would be near
impossible to design
at it would be a very expensive
challenge to do
however that's one of the perks of being
an architect is sometimes these projects
land on your desk so
if i go back around to this site and
look at this little peninsula we have a
beautiful peninsula that spans into the
water and if i turn my mass vegetation
back on you'll see
that it is completely covered in
greenery and shrubbery
all the vegetation has turned on and it
is a very
nice wilderness environment in a very
private secluded beach
so the goal of today is to try and
create a single beautiful residence
hanging on that single pad that we've
created
it's a very small piece of land in
comparison to the rest of the site that
we've modelled
but it will look phenomenal in this
landscape so i'm thinking because the
land is quite small we're not going to
be able to create anything
extravagant or anything gigantic that
has a hundred million rooms but that
makes it good for us as well
okay so i've moved to emotional way and
now we're back in archicad
and this red square is that landing pad
that i was talking about before
so we have approximately 25 meters by 18
meters to work with
which is roughly give or take a random
household block in australia
so theoretically you could probably fit
a 4x2 home on this
quite comfortably and be able to create
something phenomenal
but i'm thinking because it is a private
beach dwelling
we are more so going to be looking on
that holiday retreat
villa kind of style design depending on
the hemisphere you're
designing in you may either want to
locate all of your living rooms to the
north or all of your living rooms to the
south
in this instance we want to locate them
all on the north side
and have our sleeping in the south side
at the same time we don't want to be
missing out on this spectacular view
so what i'm gonna actually try and
accomplish with this is to recess the
bedrooms as far
south as possible without actually
losing that northern elevation
in my mind north is facing this way so
the front of the building is going to be
on the left-hand side of this page
considering that it is an oceanfront
design we're probably going to be
sticking with materials like concrete
just so that we don't have to worry
about rust or anything in the future
okay so the first thing we want to set
up is our story levels in this so we
don't have to mess around with it and
play with it so we go into
these story settings by pressing command
seven i'm going to rename my ground
floor
to mountains and i'm going to rename my
first floor to ground floor
and then i'm going to adjust my height
to 7
250 millimeters because i've already had
to play around with it and
know that that floor over on twin motion
is 7 250 above sea level
so don't be messing around having to
constantly rotate my head
around 90 degrees but i also don't want
to mess with the orientation of the twin
motion file
so what i'm going to do is go down the
bottom and actually change my
orientation by 90 degrees and completely
flip the design without messing with the
actual orientation settings
and we can begin working so the base of
this building is going to be the living
spaces and i usually start
by creating just some generic squares to
understand
size proportion and things like that so
if we were to design a living room and a
dining room we'd probably give that
living room seven meters
by anywhere from five meters to seven
meters again because we're going for
that nice elongated design in my opinion
on this one
we want another dining room to match it
so another five meters
by five meters is more than sufficient
that is a very
giant dining room and you can easily cut
that in half
if you're restricted by space however in
this instance we're definitely not
restricted in any way shape or form
we're gonna have to have some sort of
parking so a six by six
garage is pretty typical to be able to
actually
facilitate two cars in the actual
property
and then we wanna have at least one
bedroom and a master bedroom is
anywhere from four meters to five meters
in this instance
i'm going to pick 400 meters by 4 meters
and then start manipulating the shapes
messing around with them like a tetris
game to actually be able to create
something phenomenal
now just to point out this is the first
time i'm making this design
i've just finished this textured model
on the left for twin motion and i have
absolutely no idea what i'm doing
so this is just me going from experience
and trying to create something that i
think will work here
and massage it throughout the process to
actually create something great so like
i said a minute ago we want to create
our bedroom set back a little bit
and we want to have some sort of
alfresco dining as well
so in this instance i think it would be
really nice to have a beautiful
wraparound balcony around the whole side
of this building
that cantilevers over those rocks as far
as possible
so i'm envisioning a very low monolithic
structure
that wraps and curves around very
similar to how that
island does itself however we're missing
a substantial amount of information here
because we've got a garage we've got a
living
we've got a dining and a bedroom we have
no bathrooms we have no kitchens we have
nothing of the sorts
so in this instance i'm actually going
to utilize this empty space here
and whatever size i create is going to
be my kitchen
so now just to color coordinate things
i'm going to just change colors around
so we know that we're looking at
different
shapes and different areas of the house
i'm not really picking any colors in
particular i'm just picking colors
off a random sort now considering this
is a very hypothetical scenario and
you'd have to have an endless budget to
create it
i think it is reasonable to assume that
we can create this balcony that wraps
around
anywhere from three to six meters
cantilevering off the side of the cliff
so if i run that three meters off the
side of the bedroom
and then another three meters off the
side of the front of the building we can
come back to that in a minute and
potentially increase that to six metres
if we need it
but for the time being three meters is
quite a nice cantilever
i know that this is the edge of my rock
or my slab so i can
continue to move that a little bit
further down
and utilize that cantilever of the
balcony to
form back into the rocks if i need to
so right now we have our garage that
pulls into the back
our kitchen our bedroom our dining and
our living space so this is our main
entertaining space
our beautiful wrap around alfresco and
then what i actually want to utilize on
this side of the balcony
is more so some private retreat style
bathrooms
so instead of creating a very large
bathroom i'm going to create a very long
and very wrap-around bathroom so in this
instance the bathroom for me
is going to look something like an
l-shape i'm thinking that there might be
a nice
shower over here or even a bathtub and
the rest of the requirements like the
walk-in robe and the showers and the
taps and
all the bits and bobs can be stored
around so that is going to be the
fundamental
design principles of this one-bedroom
luxury villa
that overlooks the water on a fantastic
beautiful site and we're going to start
by creating the exterior profile so we
can see
if we've actually managed to put that
perfectly where we want it on
that twin motion file so what i'll do is
get the slab tool
make sure it's on the right layer for me
i'm happy with slab
and actually create my slab by holding
space
and clicking on the fill that i've
already started to use
and then i can delete that fill there
what i want to do next is create some
walls before i go into the windows and
the glass of anything
so i'm going to start with a 200
millimeter concrete panel and
just begin by tracing the outside of
this house that we've
started to create and visualize in our
head i think that this rear carport
doesn't have to be a carport in itself
or it doesn't have to be a concealed
garage sorry it can be some sort of
carport
so i'm going to leave that off the plans
for the time being i'm also envisioning
some sort of front door patio
area next to this carport
bedroom i'm also envisioning some sort
of alfresco
entry over here next to the garage or
carport
so i'm just going to annotate it here
for the time being and then continue to
move through the process
if we jump into 3d we're going to see
where our house is starting to sit
and what we can actually do is already
direct link it to twin motion to see if
it's lining up with our project
so now i've brought that project back
into twin motion and it actually isn't
aligning with where i wanted it to
and you can see that my vegetation is
causing me some trouble so i'm going to
just turn that layer off
now i think the house is definitely
rotated the wrong way and i've
established that starting ground point
the wrong way so i'm going to rotate the
whole house
about 45 degrees to be able to move it
over
and cantilever further over this cliff
face
okay so i've repositioned my house
somewhere where it fits a lot better
on this actual landing pad and as you
can see we have plenty of room if we
wanted to make this house bigger
smaller add more rooms go up do whatever
we want introduce
an interior atrium which is something
that i'd actually be thinking about in
this project just to
really bring that unity in so we're
going to bring it back
over to our actual archicad file and
then continue
manipulating this ground floor to be
able to better
utilize the actual space that we have so
to continue making this a phenomenal
project what i'm going to do is actually
extend that balcony
another two meters and also extend it
another meter on the side
like i said before the garage is here is
going to be that main carport entrance
which i'm no longer liking the
positioning of that so i'm going to drag
it
a lot further back to the rear of the
site so it isn't as intrusive
i'm also going to introduce a secondary
bedroom on this side of the property
they can get those beautiful panoramic
views of the mountains
as well as an ensuite so to reintroduce
the elements of water into this design
what i also want to do
is introduce a lap pool that doubles as
a pond of the entry feature
so what i'm going to do is extend this
lap pool all the way through
and then utilize my entry over the top
so
my entry is going to form some sort of
beautiful cascading effect with stepping
stones through the water and then this
is going to transition into a small lap
pool so we're going to be surrounded by
nature and water as much as possible by
creating that pool and that entry of the
water
and having it overlooking the entire
beautiful beach
what i'm thinking at the same time is
it'd be quite nice if we had some sort
of bridge that connected this space and
the rear space that would create a
secondary living quarters or a secondary
bedroom slash granny flat so in my head
i'm thinking we could do
another six and a half by six which is
big enough for a bedroom and a bathroom
and then some sort of staircase
connecting these two elements over here
so that's something we'll explore a
little bit down the track and it might
not be something that we actually
eventuate
but we'll continue to play with this
design as it continues to
evolve and progress with the site and
the ideas that come organically
as we continue to design so now the
actual shape of the building has changed
so what we'll do
is delete our perimeter walls and start
redrawing them again
i think that's the quickest and easiest
way at this stage so you don't have to
redesign a million times now if north is
still up the page we would definitely
still be shading our building
with way too much of an awning over the
top and we would be having
an issue getting light into this
building so in order to be able to get
the light in as much as possible i think
it would be nice to be able to penetrate
this section of the slab and the
cantilevering awning
to be able to get that natural light
into this building as much as possible
throughout the entire day
but we'll come back to that in a second
and we'll begin with working on the
internals of this actual space
so again i'm thinking that the main
entry is going to be here so we're going
to be focusing on
this area as our kitchen living dining
and as these two as our separate spaces
for the bedrooms so if we continue to
work on the internals we'll
begin by using some sort of brickwork
because we're already using masonry so
we're going to have most of similar
trades already on site
we'll go 90 mil mill block work internal
wall
and for the purposes of this we're
simply just going to draw some shapes
to outline the externals of our
rooms so i can envisage this being a
glass tunnel or a glass walkway that you
can swim under
quite elegantly and quite naturally and
also reflecting
this area of the garden and the entryway
this probably needs to be some sort of
landscaping some sort of tree growing
through the center
and then again incorporating that atrium
that i was previously speaking about
but without having the costs of an
atrium so i think i'll designate that as
landscaping later on
down the track and it'll continue to be
that pond design that we were talking
about
so if we take this slab and start to
create some sort of stepping stones and
some sort of feature on the entry
let's say we have 800 by two meter wide
stepping stones
and i'm going to delete that to be able
to actually create this
stepping stone here the stepping stone
for me will be somewhere in the center
of this pool
which is 450 millimeters away and we're
going to have about a 100 mil
gap so i'm going to quickly and
easily space them 900 millimeters apart
so by pushing them across we have 900
millimeters
i'm going to go one step back so we're
not impeaching on this landscaping that
we're talking about previously
and then i'm just going to extend these
last two slabs straight to the house
so the house actually has some sort of
entryway and this will be our door
we'll begin creating our kitchen here in
a second but i also want to create a
floating island
here for this planter that we're
thinking of creating in the future
so we'll create a circular planter
delete that
go back into our 3d and see that it's
all changed
re-manipulated and we have a very
different
environment on our hands already we're
looking at a much larger house
so we'll directly link that back into
twin motion to see
that we haven't gone a little bit
overboard and
we haven't ruined what we're thinking
okay so to me to be able to make this
house fit we've had to push it quite far
back
we've designed that driveway to come up
right into that garage which is working
really well that main entry is going to
come into the back side we're going to
see some incredible views as we're
walking in
and our balcony is going to be
cantilevering straight across
i do feel like it's missing some sort of
natural element some sort of organic
form
on the right hand side of this building
so it can actually
cantilever further across that side so
i'm potentially even thinking
that this balcony here will form
some sort of wrap around curve shape so
if we were to draw a couple lines and
just manipulate
these elements before we take it any
further and just see what we can come up
with
potentially i'm thinking we might be
able to wrap around a nice big curve
on the front and have that really come
out as much as possible
but that in itself isn't far enough for
me i think it needs to be
something more unique something more
along those lines
so what i'm going to do is utilize that
shape
and add to the slab itself
okay so now that slab is a much more
organic shape it's wrapping around the
side
and if we link it back into twin motion
we're going to see
that shape again piercing through those
rocks camping across it
and extending past the building and the
actual
rock line itself so we're not
cantilevering an
absurd amount here at all we're only
canceling maybe about three four meters
there
and a very tiny amount here but we are
on a very
uneven un natural rock surface so all of
that would have to be cleared and
brought back
onto the actual building structure when
it was completed
so in my head i'm thinking this would
have a flat concrete roof that
replicates
the bottom side of that decking or the
balcony whatever we're going to call it
and bringing it across we're having that
tony stark-like
looking building floating majestically
across the front of the hill and all of
this structure in itself
is not correct it's not modeled
correctly none of these layers are
correct but
we're not really talking about that in
this video we're more talking about
design and design inspiration
so from here like i was talking about we
want to get some natural light coming in
but we want to follow this shape here i
think putting a circle in or anything
natural and organic would just look
silly so what i'm going to do is
actually
replicate this line once again to be
able to bring it inside the building and
actually cut away some of the natural
elements that we've created already
and there we go we have a nice big
triangle that is going to let
an abundance of light right into this
building throughout the day
which is exactly what we're looking for
so to facilitate the rest of the house
i'm going to quickly draw this
slab over the entirety of the house and
then we're going to create the rest of
the roof design
later on but for the time being it's
just a very
simple flat roof that sits
over the top of the entire house it will
be significantly thicker than that
that's 250
it'll probably be about 350 if not more
and now we're starting to see our
structure come into shape
what we're also going to do with the
bottom slab is recreate that to 350
mil to give it symmetry more so than
anything else
and we're going to start changing some
materials around
so this will be concrete the actual
roof itself will be concrete as well now
i believe
most of this area is going to be glass
as much as possible
so we're going to actually utilize this
as a panoramic
window by simply using some of the
window tools in archicad
okay so now we have our windows in place
for that main living space
and all of this section is completely
exposed to the sun
so we're going to be able to extend that
roof over the top
and actually give it some sort of
protection in australia you probably
only need about 600 to 900 ml of an
overhang depending on where you are
to be able to actually get that natural
sunlight in so anything over that is an
overkill
in this instance i'm going to go 600 mil
just to give it a small little overhang
and then at the same time i'm going to
wrap around this side
of the architectural slab at the bottom
not for anything more so than symmetry
in
this design so as we see it if we link
back into twin motion
the wrap around that slab is purely an
aesthetic feature
that is there to complement the top of
that concrete wall
so as you can see this building is
starting to look fantastic
there is no way we'll cantilever that
roof that far
so we may actually have to introduce
some sort of column structure
right so we'll go back into archicad and
we'll just introduce a small column
member
over on this side to be able to actually
get some realism into this project
so so a simple round column will be more
than enough in this instance to be able
to facilitate
most of that structure there the
engineers will probably disagree with me
but we can make that work later down the
track
so now we have a phenomenal structure
sitting over the side of a cliff
which doesn't really interact with this
side of the beach at all and it's quite
a big walk to get down to the beach
so i'd definitely be introducing some
sort of steps
or some sort of natural landscaping
coming down here to be actually able to
enter into the water
that's probably something we can do in
twin motion because it's already
generated all of these rocks and all of
these shrubs are individual
so we have the ability to remove edit
and adjust accordingly
between now going back into archicad we
can continue developing the interior of
our property
so we know that this is going to be a
bedroom we don't need that we know that
that's going to be part of the bedroom
that's the kitchen that's living that's
the dining and
that is the hallway we have here the
hallway
gives us 600 mil wide which is nowhere
near enough
so we'll extend that another 600
millimeters and
connect these two elements to be able to
actually
walk in that space and re-center that
landscaping strip
so we already know where all of our
spaces are going we know what we're
doing
internally so we can get rid of those
elements there
and we can continue working on the rest
of the design
now i don't want this video to go
forever and i don't want it to
absolutely bore you so we're just going
to continue
with the actual overall exterior design
of this building
and we're going to focus on the master
bedroom next now the master bedroom is
also going to have some sort of window
at the front that takes up
the entirety of that wall but also
keeping in mind that we do have
a bathroom connecting next to it so we
are going to bring that window
across as much as possible but at the
same time we're going to introduce as
much
smaller skinnier picture frame window on
this side
which will act as that bathroom window
with the million dollar views outside
if anything you might even create a
corner window wrapping around
but if we look back at our 3d model
there isn't too much looking out of this
corner so if i was to fly into this
space
we would notice that the majority of the
view is directly out this way and
anything to the left is rocks boulders
and natural vegetation so we want to
aim most of our views and most of our
focus over here so that would be the
main master bedroom we could introduce
some additional walls in here so for
example
that could become the master bathroom
that could become the robe and then we
could facilitate
all of the services in there and keep
the master
we could then also reintroduce a wall at
the rear here
and return that wall lower so that the
front
door to that actual bedroom was along
the side
hidden away and not directly from the
main living space
similar to this one it's in the hallway
so it is not a big deal we can
facilitate that and hide that completely
and
this one will do something with the
kitchen design it could form part of the
scullery
or some sort of entry feature portico
nook but we can
discuss that element a little bit later
down the track now as we continue to
work our way around
these glass this glass tunnel will be
pivotal
in the grand entry and the overall
statement that you make with this house
even though it's probably grand enough
as it is on its own
so going back into our 3d we see we're
elaborating those glass walls on the
external
we have this beautiful picture frame
glass window
facilitating from one side to the other
and which will be our pool and our pond
underneath
wrapping through the house touching it
all the way and coming back
into the side of the house so to
facilitate that pool and that design
we're actually going to start by using
the same concrete panel
and unlinking it from the next level so
we're not going to link it
we're going to make that 1.8 deep we're
going to make that 1.8 below natural
ground level
and then we're just going to start
drawing in the pool as we see fit
so in my belief the pool will sit
directly
under the house and will continue to
draw it
all the way around and wrap it back to
this side
so if this was the pool it is way too
high up again
so we will just lower the pool so it
sits at
natural ground level and we will then
create a slab
that connects the two so that'll be our
lap pool now
it'll also form part of our actual entry
and its statement itself so these
stepping stones will go
through the pool this section the pool
will only be a couple hundred
millimeters deep
and then it will rapidly drop down just
underneath that tree and underneath the
house
to four meters deep or two meters deep
whatever we decide to make the pool
and making sure we leave enough
clearance under that house so the water
is never touching it and it is a literal
bridge over the top
it's going back into our ground floor
plan what i'm going to do
is select out alfresco and
start boxing out the actual building
itself so we have some sort of
floor in the property and then i'm also
going to facilitate
that pool that we're speaking about and
model it as just
random water or anything that i can
really find
so now we're walking over that water in
that infinity pool
stepping over it there's going to be a
beautiful tree here overlooking the
landscaping
hiding that creating some sort of
natural privacy
to the rear of this little dip pool on
this side here
which will reconnect into the actual
living room by facilitating some sort of
windows in this bedroom and in this
bedroom and then
also throughout the living and the entry
to be able to actually
reconnect that interior to exterior
design
this carport i'm not entirely sure if
we'd want to make it completely
weatherproof would we want to make it an
open
carport to be able to facilitate those
beautiful summer days
and it could be something like a natural
landscape carport
so in my head i'm thinking it could be a
four column
post structure that would then just have
rafters over the top
and it would be quite minimalistic and
modern and tie back into the whole
design of the house
so we could also then bring these
rafters all the way across and create
some sort of
covered walkway for the house but we're
probably getting ahead of ourselves
at this very minute so what i'm thinking
for the carport is something along these
lines with just a timber structure over
the top
facilitating that entire building there
and then we could potentially wrap that
side round to protect it from the
mountains and to protect it from the
weather
so by simply recreating our columns we
can wrap around that side
personally i don't like that which is
one of the fun bits about actually being
able to design before you can construct
you can quickly
go back in and you can remove everything
that you've just done
and go back to the original to be able
to see what was better what worked nicer
so my personal opinion i think that is a
much better much cleaner design
versus what we had originally so i'm
going to actually keep
this as the predominant structure
for the carport at the time being i
definitely see it as a wood structure
more so than anything
so it would be something along these
lines with the actual
timbuk wrapping around i'm not sure if
there'd be some sort of feature wrap
around corner at the end
but that would be more detail if the
client was happy with the overall
design of the house so then the house
would continue to evolve and we would
continue to design
and make sure every element fits however
the overall design the overall concept
would be something along these lines if
we bring it back into twin motion we'll
be able to see where we've come to
so we see that we have this beautiful
house cantilevering over the cliffside
we have the driveway wrapping from the
beach moving all the way up
to the top where we have our carport and
we'll park our cars
so if we just randomly drop a car in
here for the purposes
of argument we know it's going to be a
very nice range rover looking car
so we'll position that in our carport
and bring it over to the side
and we also know that this would be our
pool
so because it's already a sculpted form
we can continue to decrease this and
showcase our water
then the house would continue to have
some sort of landscaping like we
discussed it'd be a small
but beautiful tree here in the middle it
would probably be something
that could survive in the harsh climate
of australia especially
right next to the ocean but it would
also be something protected
it'd have to be something relatively
small i think that's definitely too big
so we're definitely going to be looking
for a tiny little tree
it would probably be something like a
frangipani in this instance
but i don't think twin motion has a
fringe penny so i'll create this
tropical tree here for the purposes of
the design
and now you'd see we'd have this grand
entry coming
up with a footpath at the back for the
perfect viewing platform
you'd see the edge of the house
cantilevering across
and if you were to wrap around you'd see
the actual beautiful home
completely hanging over the cliff and
would also indicate some sort of steps
along this side of the rock face or the
cliff face to be able to get into the
water
as we see fit but overall that would be
the design principles we'd go through
guys we'd establish
our zones internally we'd understand the
landscape we'd understand the site as
best as possible
we'd understand the orientation of the
facility and the site
and then work around those elements
there'd obviously be some sort of brief
to it as well which means they'd want
four bedroom five bedrooms two bathrooms
whatever
in this instance we're literally just
throwing something on paper whatever
we're thinking of and we're just
mixing and matching however we can to be
able to create
something in a space where it was
absolutely nothing before
so i hope you enjoyed that tutorial of a
very muddled brain
exercise to be able to really showcase
how an architect's brain
works and how we piece together puzzles
and solve things like in a tetris game
to be able to facilitate the best
building we can
i'll probably end up developing this
model a little bit further and posting
it on my instagram so if you do want to
follow there to see what this
actually does progress and become be
sure to follow me there's a link down in
the description below
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and as
always i will see you
next monday